I think the whole question that Anita
was asking is about chance and how we
can ensure that girls like Anita and
many many many other girls in developing
countries will have the chance for
access to education and making their
lives better and therefore the whole
economy and better as well as reducing
poverty providing that chance means
partly breaking down cultural values and
traditions about the fact that girls are
measured in the in terms of their
success in life by getting married and
having children girls need to have
access to education they need to be able
to continue their education and for this
affirmative policies may be necessary
governments as well as other ways to
ensure that those are not taking taken
out of school because of poverty or for
other reasons and especially during this
crisis where poverty rates moogle
incomes will come down there is a real
danger of girls being taken out of
school before boys will be taken out of
school so in designing policies as a
policy maker in designing policies in
managing a crisis I think we have to
really make sure that we exclusively
include this aspect to make sure that
girls continue to be in school for
instance you can build in cash transfer
programs to be given to it in with the
condition that the recipient continues
to have girls and boys stay in school in
a more medium term I think how to change
cultural values and traditions becomes a
much more a longer-term issue but having
role models having girls understand that
their self-esteem should not just be
measured by the fact that they're
married and having children needs to be
changed and I think democracy as in the
case of Indonesia has played an
important role where you find all the
way from a president being a woman to
ministers to governors to village
it's being women and making decisions
that are in favor of women as well as
being role models become a very
important part of the change and finally
I think the legal part making sure that
girls and women understand their rights
and so then if they succeed in business
they have the property rights and they
don't lose it because just because
everything is under their husbands name
so it was a good session and I would
hope that a big message coming out of
the World Economic Forum Davos is that
all the crisis messages about trade and
finance that in managing this crisis we
must have a very proactive and specific
policy to ensure that girls like Anita
will continue to have the chance and you